[Music]
look what I become
yeah
what a night last night oh my God was
was that crazy or what started at six
o'clock it was supposed to be four hours
it's midnight people are not leaving
we're asking people to live if you
missed it do not miss the next live
podcast we do at 59.90 Federal uh matter
of fact if you want to be added to the
list with the next guest them with the
moment we announced the VIP goes first
uh if you want to be added to the list
last time we had Giuliani Dave Rubin
debate screaming hollering a meme if you
we can show this meme this isn't this is
actually what the mayor said last night
and he said I don't know what a meme is
if he can show this Rod but I know what
I know what a dick is
these are lines you have to be there it
was so nice of Rudy to have you on his
podcast yeah he allowed you to maybe get
a couple words in that was weird
if you guys want to get the notice for
the next woman we're doing this remember
text award podcast to 3103
401132 arapa let's put that in the chat
in the comment section as well text
award podcast to
310-340-1132 to be to know the moment we
announce the next live because last
night was absolutely epic yeah but by
the way I mean I'm gonna give three
shout outs shout out to Dave Rubin and
Rudy Giuliani it was just awesome it was
great to hang with those guys we had
dinner before the podcast having fun
Rudy's lady Dave's friends it was
awesome the value Tanners that showed up
I mean we've got such an awesome
audience awesome base that we got
whether they love me or hate me or all
of us they just it's always respectful
smart intellectual we've got such a a
great crew and then our crew shout out
to the team man oh my God I mean whether
it's Eric Jorge Kelly Mario
just the squad is doing and Rob over
here fake money wow everybody it was
just I'm very proud of the team how
impressed were you guys with Giuliani 80
years old I every I wasn't waiting 78
bro don't go there my bad um
Dave's like I don't think we need to
have an 80 year old president and he
opened his mouth hey hey hey Dave yeah
he was sitting right next to him compare
him to like a bite him but he's well
spoken he's long-winded but everything
was was on point one funny thing I
actually saved it for the end of the
night I got in in the Cigar Lounge and
he's sitting there and it's like Pat
smoke it's like my field so I go I go
hey uh Hey mayor I have um I'm from New
York my name is Vincent he's like shakes
my hand I go thank you for as a New
Yorker you clean up the streets you did
everything my family you know they're
happy but there is one problem and he's
like what's that all of his team turns
around I go you got rid of all the
prostitution on 42nd Street and he was
like nodding and I go my sister hasn't
worked
answers and he laughs he goes oh you're
the comedian I go yeah yeah give me your
sister's number I'm gonna call her first
but getting back to work on the street
but a night from from beginning to end
it was just it's one of those nights
where you sit back and you're like holy
[__] we did it was a great night so last
night was a lot a lot of politics a lot
of politics today we're going to talk uh
business musk had a few comments to
Chuck Schumer uh after Trump's arrest
that's semi-politics Pelosi event turns
chaotic that is semi politics anti-war
protesters uh-oh but there's a few
things going on with business here
private payrolls Rose by 145 000 in
March well below expectation ADP says
higher March jobless claims add to sign
of cooling labor market job cuts are
almost up 400 percent this year has
jobless claims rise bank failures High
inflation Rising rates is the resilient
job market about to crack that's a wsj
Wall Street Journal story gen Z is sick
and Thai tired of their jobs bosses want
hard workers this is also Wall Street
Journal story check this out folks boss
want hard workers so they're hiring
older people okay it's a shout out to
younger people Twitter labels MPR as
state Affiliated and media you gotta see
this Walmart's a 65 percent of their
stores will be surface serviced by
Automation in three years let me say
that one more time 65 of their stores
will be serviced by Automation in three
years not 30 years not 20 years not 10
years not five years in three years
Boomers home buying Bonanza luxury home
sales plunge 45 with Miami and Hampton
Hamptons hitting the hardest you know
we're going to be making some aggressive
offers in the next couple months
California residents need to make this
much money to be happy wait till you see
what this number is for Californians to
be happy but before we go find out how
to make Californians happy let me give a
quick shout out to our sponsors
Masterworks at a crazy time like this
with everything that's going on with
Silicon Valley Bank with I'm watching
Jamie Diamond they're asking them a
question do you think Jamie just
yesterday do you think Jamie a few other
banks are going to go out of business
and well you know there may be a few
other brands the way he just said is
like yeah it's not really a big deal
there may be a few other Banks going out
but it's going to be okay it's going to
be did you see that the way he said it
translation yeah I'm gonna go shopping
pretty soon exactly and he he has all
the money in the world to be able to do
that the one thing that is becoming
talked about by a lot of people in the
investment world is alternative
Investments alternative assets and one
of them is Art just to kind of give you
an idea what happened last year last
year was the best auction year ever
where the highest total big three
auction houses did 18 billion dollars
last time inflation was this High
Contemporary Art appreciated at an
average of you ready 20 per year so
these guys here at Masterworks they got
now nearly 660 000 members you know it's
By Invitation Only You have to wait to
get into the system of what they have
going on what you're able to do to do is
you can buy Picasso painting but rather
than you buying the whole thing you get
to buy a share of the Picasso painting
you get to buy a share of the Banksy
they do all the paperwork they do all
that stuff you just go and you buy stock
into it and then if you appreciates you
can sell it and they have a system for
it everything is done by the SEC so if
you guys want to learn more about these
guys approved by the SEC meaning they're
doing they're qualified with the SEC and
broken into shares if you want to learn
more about Masterworks uh and to get an
invitation click on the link below
masterworks.art forward slash PVD
podcast once again masterworks.art
forward slash pbd podcast purchase
shares and great masterpieces like Pablo
Picasso Banksy Andy Warhol and more so
let's get right into it Tom
private payrolls Rose by 145 000 jobs
and 145 000 in March well below
expectation ADP says Okay so this was a
topic that everybody was talking about
the last 24 hours
um this is down from an upwardly revised
261 000 in February down below Dow Jones
estimate of 210 000 the first quarter
hiring average around 175 000 jobs a
month a sharp reduction from the average
of 397 just a year ago in first quarter
okay according to adp's Chief Economist
Nella Richardson the March payroll data
is one of several signals that the U.S
economy is slowing down employers are
pulling back from a year of strong
hiring and pay growth with pay growth
now in inching down job growth was
almost evenly split between services and
goods producing firms which is unusual
the US economy is heavily service
oriented so the services sector
generally produces much stronger hiring
gains Tom why should we care about this
number so there's a couple numbers to
care about this morning and first of all
happy Good Friday everybody and
hopefully we give you some good ideas
and some things to use with these stats
as you manage your life in your business
there's a couple things going on here
Pat do you ever have like your favorite
basketball team plays and you see a
couple things that happen and what
happened
maybe at the net really started like 45
seconds ago at the other end of the
court and things were forming and they
come together or it's your favorite
football team and you see something
happen you say it really wasn't the
touchdown you have to go two plays
before that momentum being built up
correct and things happening well here's
here's what's interesting happening and
Rob if you could be ready with the chart
I sent you
right now there are three things that
are moving together right now that are
very bad it is the change in job
openings is dropping so number the
number of job openings is dropping when
we saw the uh layoffs a week ago with
meta remember part of the meta was where
we're laying off 4 000 more people but
we're canceling 5 000 open jobs so
people that day that went online looking
hey Matt has got like 5 000 engineering
jobs poof they were gone so they call
that net 9000 so they eliminated nine
thousand jobs so those job openings are
going away at an increasing rate number
one and number two the private payrolls
Rising less than expected means there
was hiring but less hiring than was
expected number two and then number
three the percent change in quits is
dropping through the floor
let me explain quits the government
actually tracks a number of people that
quit jobs and this is before they get an
unemployment check because when your
social security number is with the IRS
and you're going to get a W-2 they know
who you work for and if you change jobs
at the end of the year you get two W-2s
one for this job one for that job so the
government can track when your social
security number moves from one company
to another and they call that a quit or
a job change and so they get the stats
so what you have everything coming
together here
um there's a chart that if can they see
that right now perfect so you take a
look at this this is by regions and
there's a government chart that you can
look at any time you want called joltz
j-o-l-t-s which is job openings and
labor turnover survey and it'll tell you
like the temperature of your region of
what's going on for the job economy and
right now
job openings are down lowest since 2021
layoffs are up and it's not just Tech
and quits are down so people with jobs
are not quitting at the same rate they
were in any of the previous three years
Pat remember it was fashionable to quit
walk across the street tell them and I
want to work from home and I want to
bring my dog to work and I only want to
work four days all those things and I
want 20 more and employers were kind of
desperate for workers and so during
covet sometimes they said yes so the
workers kind of had this leverage point
and as you've said on the podcast a lot
of times workers overplayed their hand
because three years later they're
looking for layoffs and the boss is
saying okay who took me to the bank
what's unique about this little town so
what's unique about this what what is
this saying these all of these things
coming together are saying that we have
a very soft job market right now and
you've got the Wall Street Journal CNBC
and the official business magazine of
China Forbes they're all saying the same
thing saying look out the word is look
out it's like this is think of it this
way Pat there is a check engine light on
the jobs part of the US economy we have
installed we haven't pulled over yet but
when you take a look at everything here
job openings down
fewer people hired and fewer people
quitting that means the entire job
market is nervous well maybe let me read
this other stuff so this kind of gives
you a little bit of what you're trying
to say job cuts are almost up 400 this
year as jobless claims rise okay so this
is a specifics the job Cuts have nearly
sharpened risen sharply with roughly job
Cuts risen sharply with roughly 270 000
job Cuts so far this year 396 increase
from last year what was that percent
396 oh so that's big that's a very big
number on what they're talking about the
tech sector was hit the hardest for job
Cuts according to accounting for 38 of
all the layoffs this year Financial
companies came in second accounting for
11 percent of layoffs Giants such as
Amazon Google and meta fired over 10 000
and it's not even slowing down Adam you
were going to say something yeah well
look if you're anything like me like I'm
reading all these reports right here and
if you focus on all this it is so easy
to get anxious and stressed out like if
you just read any of these headlines JB
Diamond Wards the banking crisis has
raised the odds of recession U.S health
system will go bankrupt the next few
years more signs pointing towards an
eminent slowdown private payrolls rolls
154 000 below expectations higher
jobless claims more jobs Cuts more jobs
Cuts bank failures High inflation it's
like holy [__] what does this mean for
me right because at the end of the day
Tom is more of a macro guy and I'm more
of a personal finance guy you could take
all this stuff and you have to look in
the mirror and be like okay what am I
going to do you know how they say that
like degrees pay fees and skills pay the
bills you have to look in the mirror and
see am I where I need to be skill-wise
am I you know Warren Buffett says the
number one way to be inflation proof or
Recession Proof is to actually just be
good at your job yeah okay so with all
this chaos going on in the economy it's
so easy to feel overwhelmed like I'm
sure Vinnie's head's about to explode
with all these numbers I'm gonna throw
up but but if you're Vinnie yeah you're
Rob if you're me are you showing up to
work every day are you putting in the
work are you improving are you out
working are you out strategizing and
that's the only way to outlast in a
rough economy because every every day
there's a new report the economy is a
recession inflation actually we're
getting better oh no yeah hold on stock
market Bitcoin up down yeah I don't know
what to make of it but if I'm you
I have to take a deep breath and be like
okay what can I do to control what's
going on you know they say that there's
two things in life things that matter
and things that you can't control or
where you can focus is where those two
things intersect you can't control
everything and not everything matters
but where they diverge is where you
should focus and so I would sum it up
step up from the macro and and thank you
for the nudge is if you've got a good
job keep it
right now is the wrong time to walk
across the street for a five percent
difference in salary if you've got if it
show some loyalty if you own a business
and so many people so many value
chainers out there are business owners
when we had our last live event it's
like 70 of people in the audience are
business owners and thank you for your
support right now is a time to look
around and if you need to make an
upgrade of a key position you probably
have a hungry person that might show up
at the door as opposed to a couple years
ago so maybe now is the time to make an
upgrade and Now's the Time to show some
love to your great people and the people
that maybe wear pains you may be
opportunities to upgrade them now and
Pat you've we've had this conversation
many times I know we brought this up a
couple podcasts ago about whether it's
good time to ask for a raise stay loyal
loyalty what's being rewarded you know
over covid
things were so up things that went down
but I know you have strong feelings on
what employees should be doing in this
type of situation and how employers
should respond to that right yeah look I
mean I understand the message you're
given your message is hey you know uh uh
be careful reading a lot of these
stories because you're gonna be scared
and you're going to be this and you know
focus on yourself and yeah you're right
all of that stuff is fine but people are
here because they actually want to know
like what's going to happen to the
economy right they're here because they
want to get our feedback our opinion on
is this the time are we getting close to
it what should we do and you know they
get to make a decision for themselves we
don't have the answers we're just
processing having conversations together
I can tell you this is a real issue okay
with unemployment this is a real issue
with Unemployment uh they've been
they've been worried about this for a
minute
and even Wall Street Journal here says
bank failures High inflation Rising
rates is the resilient jobs Market about
to crack because for the longest time if
you remember the last uh speech that
Biden gave which what do you call it
when the president's given a speech from
uh from uh the the house what do you
call it State of the Union yeah and all
he bragged about was what unemployment
is at three and a half percent more jobs
than any emperor in history you're the
president and president yeah so but by
the way but so so here's the problem
what do you do when that's now gone
right the U.S labor market according to
Wall Street Journal has been resilient
despite the pandemic and economic risks
with employers adding 5.6 million jobs
since the start of 2022 which is a good
thing to talk about if you're
campaigning however recent banking
industry turmoil has raised concerns
about whether the labor market momentum
will slip quitter confidence has
declined gradually since April 29 22
okay the key word quitter confidence
indicating that workers are less
confident in their ability to job hop
that's the key here what Tom talked
about just a minute ago then they were a
year ago shorter hours amongst private
sector workers could indicate that
businesses are grown cautious and might
trim hours before laying off workers the
diffusion index which is a gauge of
broad-based job gains and losses across
Industries fell to its lowest since 2020
in February of 2023 real-time job
postings data which employment websites
could offer timely Clues
about about employers future hiring
intentions with some economic economies
suggesting that companies may pull down
job postings without laying off workers
in response to slowing sales and
heightened uh uncertainty okay so we
recently you know I'll give you an idea
for us even at home office we're running
a company so when the company says we're
Shifting the company shifted technology
okay company working with shifted
technology for about 90 days during
those it was about 60 days 70 days
during those 60 70 days we couldn't hire
anybody we couldn't hire anybody okay
because the system was updating perfect
during that 60 70 days if you can't hire
anybody normally if you if you lose
somebody what do you do you hire someone
you replace them if you lose two people
you replace them right but if you and
and that happens for a week for a month
for two months let's just say you lose
five people
you can't replace those people if
there's a freeze right and you can't
hire for that 60 70 day period well
imagine if companies are not only
letting people go but they're no longer
even hiring new people what's going to
start happening is the job that was
being done by 100 people now needs to
get done by 90 people by 80 people by 70
people by 60 people by 50 people over
which means which means some of these
companies it's either overworked but
there's a second thing to advance here's
a second thing which is scary to workers
the scary thing to workers is the
following when companies realize wait a
minute
we're getting everything done with 60
employees and we were doing it at 100
and we don't even have to do overtime
yeah we were the additional 40 employees
we had we were spending I don't know 2
million a year now we're just paying 400
000 in overtime we're still saving 1.6
million and we're doing it with
60 employees we don't need to go hire
those 40 people back maybe we had a lot
of employees here who were really not
doing [__] you're right that's the
problem because there's no more hide and
go seek and you were able to get away
without working the lazy people are
about to be exposed wow okay The
Reckless entrepreneurs are about to get
exposed okay those people who were
working doing their job being diligent
improving they're also going to be
exposed in a positive way the business
owners that didn't celebrate and get
cocky while money was so cheap in the
economic expansion they became arrogant
lazy sloppy those guys are gonna get
destroyed but the guys that improved
you know found ways to get better they
took care of their guys that were in the
office on a daily basis they're going to
be exposed in a positive way the market
is open things are things are cheap
right now companies are going to be
bought left and right opportunities are
going to come where talent's going to
leave a company because the seal wasn't
at work on a daily basis he's going to
take his talent somewhere else she's
going to take her Talent tomorrow we're
getting so many calls because we have so
many job openings right now we're doing
interviews right now on a daily basis
okay you're seeing people coming in here
we're on top of each other in this
building we can't even fit people in
this building here right now we have a
building issue we have a space issue
right now which is a great issue willing
to move here yeah then they're not even
from here they're coming from all over
the world to come and be part of the
Valentine team my office is the men's
bathroom now you know that right so
anyway keep going back in what you're
doing no that's fine that's fine when
you're like you're pooping again no
because I'm working no well you were
pooping yesterday that's the difference
but but the point here but the point
here but we have but the point here is
the fact that the the good people are
finding each other it was hard to find
each other let me replace good the
hard-working drivers who are ambitious
couldn't really identify who was who it
was too blurry two years ago today
they're like oh so you were full of [__]
this entire time yeah they're real I'm
going over there wow damn I am with the
real company thank God I'm staying put
I'm not going anywhere so that's the
thing that's going on today and by the
way I'll go to you right after this for
election if you think about election
wise this is going to hurt because to
get reelected you need to have some kind
of success or a war so you need to have
a great economy that no one's bothering
everybody's like yeah dude if the
economy is this good Let It Roll let's
go one more time with this guy yeah or
you need to have a war where it's fear
anxiety and you're like well we can't
make a disruption because we're doing
this one of those two things if you no
longer have this data to say look what a
great job we're doing with unemployment
now what day they're going to be talking
about yeah well I'll just just really
fast and Adam you brought up the point
and Pat I'm happy you brought it back
all this I've been here for next month
is going to be by one year Meg I moved
here it's crazy crazy in May wow all
this talk Adam a recession thank you the
recession the you know inflate
everything that's happening and all that
I like for someone that doesn't really
know like like as much as you guys know
I feel like like this bubble is is
getting to a point where it's gonna pop
but this Administration is like saving
it so it doesn't pop under this watch is
that what is that's what happened
because remember the White House changed
the definition of recession live what we
were we were in here and they're like no
two quarters now that's not they changed
it on Wikipedia So Adam do you feel like
they're saving it because they know it's
gonna pop but they don't want it to
happen under their watch what well yeah
any politician doesn't want something
like that to happen under their watch
yeah I think what Pat brings up is a
good point because there's basically two
parts to a company yeah there's the
employer the business owner the
entrepreneur and that's the employees
yeah okay the workers and I don't know
what percentage of the company are the
entrepreneur you know c-suite Executives
five percent ten percent ninety percent
of the company are the workers well
sometimes it's one lonely guy who
founded the company yeah yeah up in the
up in the attic yeah and he's hired all
these people yeah exactly so I think you
know Pat's more speaking to the business
owners I'm more speaking to the
employees
um I'm not a CEO I'm not a business
owner so I I never kind of step out of
place with that that's really why I
respect what Pat and bizdoc do you know
my message is usually to the employees
to the Vinnies of the world who's like
buddy you want to start a company but
yeah I'm just hire me to do your next
what do you say about this though what
do you say about we got that point what
are you saying about this about what's
the question no what about about what
what we just talked about for the last
time what do you have thoughts on this
well one thing Pat mentioned and the
diffusion index just think of that as
the thermometer on jobs and the
diffusion index is at lowest it's been
since April of 2020. Rob can you go back
to that chart you just showed
it's the lowest it's been since April
2020. would you like to see what the
market was doing in April of 2020 that
was the covid Free Fall remember that
Pat look at that
so they're saying that this temperature
gauge on jobs is as low as it's been
since then
so it's it's real folks and it's coming
and you need to manage yourself
accordingly
yeah there's there's not a this is not a
hypothetical this is coming Based on
data and by the way you know based on
that you're hearing different
Generations how they're looking at work
right you got gen z's are getting sick
and tired of their jobs okay I'll give
uh the story here and then Adam I'm
going to come to you that sounds like a
timing Gallup survey shows that from
2019 to 2022 if you can have this chart
to show it the wrap that'd be great the
shares of people under 35 who reported
being engaged with their jobs dropped
from 37 to 33 four percent not a big a
job but it's the lowest level since 2011
at the same time the share who reported
being actively disengaged Rose from 17
uh 17 to 12. five percent that's a real
number on 17 to 12. remote and hybrid
work during the pandemic is a
significant factor in the growing
workplace
disgruntled men of younger generation
young workers aren't getting enough
social interactions mentorship and
guidance from their managers and more
experienced colleagues and remote and
hybrid work environments the rise of
digital messaging tools like slack has
also made it harder for early career
employers to learn by osmosis in an
office I wonder why companies can
improve the office experience
reorganized the workplace to create more
space for people to collaborate and
socialize organize more happy hours pay
oh my God pay for parking and Subway
Place fairs by the way this sounds can
you find out who the writer of this
article is he she sounds pissed off who
is the writer okay
what Aki is saying Aki is boss please
she is asking for a parking pass or a
subway fare like a you know money there
to help her out with allow people to
arrive later she wants to come later to
work yeah and leave earlier to avoid
rush hour commutes and help facilitate
the social interactions and mentorship
the young people are otherwise missing
wait a minute wait a minute how do you
Pat you are a big Mentor starting to
interrupt but how the hell do you get
mentored by showing up later and leaving
earlier no but you know what it is
though this is a crime
tell a younger person younger people
don't want to work that hard what yeah
how the hell you move up in a company
how the hell do you move up in your in
your career Adam yeah I think there's a
four-letter word that uh young people
need to understand that it's not a bad
word and that word is work yeah okay not
up in here no not up in here not up in
here yeah I mean guys the reality is if
you're 20 years old you're going to be
working that four-letter word again work
for the next 50 years yeah okay for the
next 50 years
now you can't microwave success yeah
okay it's a slow burn [__]
there's no like oh let me just show up
to the office at 10 o'clock leave by
four check out get the parking passes
with my dog yeah yeah that's not how it
works yeah exactly okay maybe they need
like an inspirational speaker or
somebody that they can look up to since
the transgender thing is becoming a big
hit maybe there was a famous poet okay
from the transgender community and he
said you better work you better work you
better work work Genesis
[Applause]
[Music]
listen to Rupaul at work you will end up
living in a van down by the by the river
yeah I think the Gen Z needs to realize
that work and work ethic is not a bad
thing yeah it's what's going to help you
survive for the next 70 years of your
freaking life and if you're not used to
getting used to it now buddy whether
this recession happens or not it's
coming at some point so here's what's
crazy about what you're saying right now
Adam it's the next story which is funny
about this so let me let me without
ruining the story let me just read it so
one story inside of this tells you who's
writing for Insider and who's writing
for Wall Street Journal so The Insider
story is about don't work people so hard
here's a Wall Street Journal story let's
go bosses want hard workers so they're
hiring older people
and by the way older people who have
been through recessions and they know
they're like you know this could get
really bad because I'm old and I've been
through it right you know what you
better put your head down and work
you're gonna get your ass shot off all
the work all the workers are
increasingly in demand at businesses as
they're more likely to have a strong
work ethics show up on time and value
stability companies such as Kinder Care
for Learning Centers and Manpower group
have signed AARP pledge to give workers
over 50 a shot at hiring people 55 and
older are the fastest growing segment of
the workforce and the trend is driven by
demographic shifts longer lifespans and
a weak stock market
a Wall Street Journal uh nor a survey of
America's values found that
three-quarters of people 65 and older
said hard work is very important to them
personally compared to 61 percent 18 to
29 ageism remains a barrier for some
older workers but age discrimination
complaints to equal employment
opportunity commission dropped ready 45
from 2011 to 4 to 2021. hey normally the
older workers were afraid of being
replaced by the 23 year old hey 23 year
old you know what this article says to
you they're no longer scared of you
because you're lazy you don't work hard
how much does that suck FYI just so you
know this as a kid growing up if I you
know how people say well my dad always
did this and my mom already called me my
mom called me [__] my dad called me
this you know what my dad called me when
I was a kid you're lazy he said it
thousands of times when I was 14 15 16.
I was so sick of it and then I said
maybe this man is right and I went in
the Army I said you know what no I'ma
work my ass off then in a Marketplace
sits there and says you want to work
we're going to reward you we're going to
reward you Tom what do you have to say
about storyline not that you write you
you relate to the older people but yeah
what do you have to say about a story
like this
um we're seeing it and we're seeing it
and Pat and I are involved on a couple
companies and um and one's in the music
industry once in the insurance industry
and one's in media so this is pretty
diverse group and we are seeing people
that were sick and tired of maybe the
politics and the wokism and a lot of
things of large organizations looking
forward to coming back to a mid-sized
company and bringing all their
experience and skills we are seeing
interviews these interviews have been
unbelievable Pat right we say well why
do you want to do this and do this
because you guys inspire me I love the
youth that's here I love the diversity
that's here and so for many of them they
don't want to be they don't want to be
in that old environment and they're here
saying I'm going to work hard I'm going
to bring my experience and I'd love to
be part of this because it kind of
inspires me again so 23 year olds you
better be careful because that's not
that those aren't you know practiced
interview questions that is the passion
of their heart and they're willing to
come and they're coming for your job
I'll say we don't come no no
don't I'll say one thing about these
these older guys once they can figure
out how to turn their computer on yeah
yeah
but if you're giving a computer and say
hey get to work I got no clue about this
so funny laptop Twitter so I'm going to
send you something yeah open Windows
yeah the window yeah the window I don't
try the soup what's wrong with the soup
by the way like we learned yesterday
Rudy doesn't know what a meme is no he
does not know
so by the way some people are some
people say this argument when you say
something like this they say you know
you're not being sympathetic to the
younger generation okay okay no problem
or they'll say Pat the richer or the
rich are getting richer and the poor are
getting poorer okay and that's not cool
you know the wages are low they're not
paying as well as they did before no
problem let's I have a data to help you
with your argument okay so I'm very
comfortable showing data that is against
my argument but I'm going to make my
argument towards this if you can look at
this data right here check this out from
1979 1980 till today give or take okay
what this chart shows is the red you
notice at the top is the top one
percentile okay of earners in America
income games at the top dwarf those at
the low and middle income households
they're right the next is the Blue 19
it's growing but not crazy
then it's the next 60 percent that's
actually beating the 19 then you got the
bottom twenty percent okay now it's easy
for somebody to say what they're gonna
say well this is exactly the complaint
Pat it's it's exactly what happens this
is why the rich keep getting richer and
the poor keep getting poorer yes and by
the way that separation is gonna happen
and gonna get wider and wider I'm gonna
give my argument you the audience give
yours Adam Tom Vinnie you give yours
okay and you know let's learn from each
other here's my ideas couple things one
I remember you know uh I'm in the Army
me and this other guy
he says to me where is sitting in a room
and and the sergeant says to us guys
start setting aside 200 a month of your
money into Roth IRA
and I'm like Skies full of [__] you want
me to put 200 a month into Roth IRA
you're out of your freaking mind
okay so I leave my buddy we go out two
weeks later to to the club and I'm
buying drinks I'm having fun I'm like
dude how come you're not drinking he
says dude I can't I can't afford I said
dude what do you mean we make the same
amount of money we live in the same
place we we have the same exact car
payment he says yeah the difference is
I'm setting aside 200 a month on a Roth
IRA I said what a freaking boring guy
you are you freaking idiot you know and
I'm making fun of him right anyways two
and a half years later I'm getting out
of the army okay I'm etsing yeah and
yeah we're sitting there talking this
guy shows me an account says Pat look at
this it's like six or seven thousand
dollars in it he's got six or seven
thousand which some people say that's
not a lot of money Pat what are you
talking about back then yeah dude trust
me that was a lot of money because I got
out of the army with nothing and I sat
there and I'm like damn so watch this
just two and a half years ago we had the
same exact net worth
so every month his net worth was going
higher than mine by 200 bucks plus
interest on the other side less interest
on the other six So eventually the
separation between he and I got what
wider and wider and wider and wider
naturally that moment when I got out of
the army broke I understood the concept
of this freaking guy set aside 200 bucks
this lazy guy that wanted to party
non-stop with his money drank it wasn't
a long-term thinking I was drinking
party and that's what I was doing but I
learned very quickly once I got out and
I started working at Bally's I started
setting aside my money one day a year
after nine months after being at Bally's
my boss and I were sitting there to do
three of us we're at Denny's
and they had been at Bally's for nine
years I've been at Valley for nine
months they said hey man you know I'm
trying to figure this out how much cash
you got he's like dude I got no cash I'm
paycheck to paycheck I said dude you
make more money than I do how many cash
you got I got no cash on paycheck to
paycheck I'm like how much cash you got
PVD like dude I got ten thousand five
hundred dollars you got ten thousand
you've only been with us for nine months
I know bro but I'm saving everything I'm
making seriously yes bingo so this chart
shows if you
keep saving and investing and others
don't you don't separate incrementally
in a way that you think you separate
exponentially and by the way the
separation's gonna get wider and wider
and wider and wider no matter how much
you bash rich people they're gonna go
wider because while you were kicking at
wanting to work three four days a week
they're doing six days a week because
the Bible says take one day off and a
lot of people follow that guideline of
just taking one day off but everybody
wants a four day work week don't be
upset at the guy that's whooping your
ass because he's working six days a week
for ten years and you work four days
let's actually do the math boom a guy
works six days a week and only takes
Sundays off which is what I did and it's
still today that's my philosophy right
so a guy works six days and he takes one
day off over a year span what is it over
a year over a year you get 52 additional
days a year okay which is how many hours
roughly 460 15 hours because I'm doing
58 times 8 I think that's 416 hours
right so that's 52 additional days you
get per year
do you realize within six years within
seven years you got one additional year
wow within 10 years you got years within
10 years you got 520 additional days you
got 4 000 additional hours yeah brother
we're not in the same league homie sorry
we're not going to be competing in the
same league but let me give you the
other part about this that's a problem
the other problem about this that's a
problem who else is influencing this who
else is influencing this this can also
only happen with the help of the
government the more money you print the
more money you put into the economy
you're thinking you're helping the low
and middle income you don't think the
people at the top know who doing like
every time when they say Jamie Diamond
they're gonna put two trillion more
dollars into the economy Jamie's like
hell yeah because 40 of Us coming to
chase yeah 800 billion is going to end
up at whatever the number is going to be
in his mind is like that's great put two
trillion dollars I'm gonna get more on
my balance sheet you're just getting
phenomenal do you really
politicians that are sending money out
to do this you think they're sitting
there saying let's hop the low and
middle income no the money's going
straight up to the top we're going to
show you a clip here in a minute I'm
going to give you your feedback but
we're going to show you a clip here in a
minute what happened with Nancy Pelosi
you're going to be seeing what people
are saying to them how the hell did you
get so rich because you got Insider
stuff and other people are going to jail
having done one tenth of the crime you
and your husband have committed you're
seeing the protesting taking place but
the low wage the separation the
disparity all of that is you need to
start thinking long term and not joining
the camp that's convincing you to work
fewer hours is you need to figure out a
way to be more competitive in a
Marketplace when I talk to comedian
Kevin Hart he says you'd be surprised
how hard I had to work I work my ass off
okay you talk to Rogan Rogan how hard
that freaking guy works people think Joe
became Joe because Joe is just as
talented funny likable guy and he is all
of that but I know a lot of talented
funny likable guys that don't work hard
this guy was diligent focused doing what
he's doing and then all of a sudden gets
a few hundred million dollars talking
about I got a few money that's what he
said that doesn't happen by luck you
think he didn't work his ass off doing
the UFC show here traveling here over
there over this you think that schedule
is four days a week the people you
admire younger gen Z generation the
people you admire that you read about
that you watch on the sports that you're
watching movies that you're watching you
know politics or military you read about
the heroes were not four day a week
people
they did not follow that the heroes you
admire didn't follow that strategy that
is purely a propaganda being sold by a
bunch of people that went to
universities that some Professor told
them to work four days a week and
they're coming out being you know
Disciples of these prophets saying four
days a week not realizing they just
ruined somebody's Dreams by saying to
work four days a week that's my argument
you don't have to agree with it you can
bash it trash it I'm a big boy I'm
comfortable with it Tom
so everybody understands football
what if I told you hey you know what you
can play football again against me and
I'll tell you what I get four downs you
get five Downs
that's 25 that's an extra would you play
that game yeah because even if I'm
better than you as a team what an
analogy you get another chance what an
announcement and you keep coming you
would say sure I'll play that game all
day long and play that game and people I
don't think really understand that so
the second thing is you know set aside
politics
and write on a piece of paper and don't
talk to your friends and don't look at
the internet write these words on a
piece of paper why does that candidate
want my vote why
and then the next one is how are they
scaring me I heard a great talk that
boiled down to those two things the
things coming from the top pbd why does
that candidate want my vote and how are
they trying to scare me not with your
friends not to get in an argument over
the the issues that are in there just
ask yourself that question how are they
trying to scare me and why they want my
vote and you step back and all of a
sudden you realize the way they do it is
you have to become dependent on them
that is the easiest way to keep your
vote forever is to get you addicted to
the crack that is whatever program they
can offer you
if you give me one more down I'm gonna
play that game and even if you're a
better team than me I'm gonna beat you
and I am resolved to never be dependent
on anybody else and if you allow
yourself to be dependent and you allow
yourself to be bought that's where
you're going to end up but that's what I
have to say about that I love that
analogy and I'm going to try to give an
NBA analogy to you here it is the sports
audience like if I get seven thousand
yeah no I think well to use the top one
percent the next 20 and then basically
the bottom you know in the in the NBA
there's 20 guys that make 40 million
bucks a year you got LeBron you got KD
you got Steph you got Giannis these are
the All-Stars okay and then you've got
the average NBA guy that makes I don't
know five ten million bucks a year not
bad for a day's work mid-level exemption
exactly and then you got what is known
as the veterans minimum keyword minimum
and then you got guys like Udonis Haslam
that literally don't play a minute okay
and it's the equivalent of Udonis and
respect to UD if you ever see this
because he's been in the league for 20
years he's freaking my age 42 still
playing but he doesn't play and it's the
equivalent of him saying hey I'm on the
same team of Jimmy Butler I played with
LeBron I want to make what he makes yeah
well listen [__] you ain't
LeBron yeah
getting on the bench expecting to make
what the one percent make so here's the
message to like the the Bernie Sanders
and the aoc's out there they're always
trying to drive up the minimum wage the
equivalent of the veterans minimum and I
think our message is rather than trying
to fight for 12 or fight for 15 or
that's then it'll be the fight for 20.
it's like why don't you the bottom
worker
improve your skill set so because in the
average NBA current last five years okay
the average worker is going to work 50
years if you're always fighting for a
higher minimum wage what is your ceiling
it's just the minimum whatever they're
willing to Shell out and give you but if
you actually put in the work and improve
and become the LeBron or Steph of your
field the sky's the limit so by the way
some people's argument to that would be
well dude I I can't be 6A to jump 45
inches and run a you know four four
forty can be but you can in the real
world but no but wait a minute but you
can be Steph Curry yes I am you can be
Steph Curry okay so to me I fully by the
way some people are going to say you
know well Pat dude I'm not I'm not as
smart as Elon Musk you're right you'll
never be Elon Musk totally get it okay
we can we can 99.99 the world is never
going to be Elon Musk okay the
percentage of being Elon Musk is a very
very small percentage but this isn't
about you being able how much but you
can be you know a jack Richardson
working at a place that started at the
bottom and now is an executive c-suite
running media running Finance running
something Chief of Staff making 200
making 220 and then boom five years
later you got shares in the company 10
years later the company is sold it goes
public you make 3.9 million dollars on
those share like how did I become a
millionaire I never thought I was going
to be you can be that I think anybody
can be that forget about the billionaire
forget about the hector guys forget
about the DECA guys dude you can pull
that off I lived in the community the
first time I started making money and
all of a sudden I'm living in a
community all I want to know about is
how'd you make your money how'd you do
it how'd you do it how did you do it how
did you do it okay small percentage uh
you know my family I work really hard
and you find out from the other guy no
that guy got his money from his family
okay cool that was only 10 of people you
know how many people worked at a company
and then all of a sudden the company
went public
hey I worked at the company I was there
at the beginning 18 years later they
went public we sold dude I got 1.9
million dollars I couldn't even I'm a
regular guy I'm like really what did you
do there dude I wasn't even a director
or a VP I was just a manager and I
stayed there one day they gave options
I'm like why would I go anywhere else
boom anywhere else I made those are the
stories that are there those are they
say the day Microsoft went public
the number is 5 000 millionaires Mike
can you look up Microsoft public 5 000
millionaire stocks can you type that out
some story it's either Microsoft or
apple no it was Microsoft he's going to
find it and it was 32 year old
receptionist a seven regular guys a
seven year engineer that had been
working 60 hours a week and busted his
butt and was given some of those stock
options
if you got to put Microsoft not five
thousand dollars how many millionaires
did Microsoft create yeah so so the
point the point here is both of you guys
made great analogies the point here is
for for those that are defending the
four day work week and remote and all of
that [__] let me tell you what you're
defending okay I'm sorry it was 12 000
employees okay right okay it Rose to
dominate the personal computer operating
system Market with MS-DOS in the mid 80s
followed by Windows the company's 1986
initial public offering and subsequent
rise in its shares created three
billionaires and an estimated 12 000
millionaires from regular employees
these are not crazy employment people I
was describing yeah these are the people
that said dude I'm gonna stay here it's
hard I gotta work my ass off we're part
of a startup but you know what these
guys seem serious these guys seem
committed maybe something can happen so
you if you're watching like then the
opposite side is going to say but I'm
not part of something like that but then
keep open your damn eyes and find some
they're out there you can find them and
then bring value to them and say I'm
gonna do whatever I can to bring value
to this organization and if they don't
reward you trust me you're gonna find
somebody that's gonna reward you when a
good guy or a good girl goes through a
streak of one or two bad relationships
but you know this person's a good person
I'm like let me just tell you you're
gonna be fine okay you're gonna be fine
just tell the world what you're looking
for and the right person in the right
climate you're eventually going to find
them okay you have to know more people
need to know what you're looking for
they'll eventually you took the words
out of my world pack because I was when
I was saying like you have to find
places that have the culture like a
valuetainment you know I mean like you
have to come and look for it me and uh
Maverick were shooting a sketch in the
other building months ago I told you
about this Shamari who works with us
right now walked in with a suit looking
for he's like I want to work at this
type of company you know I think it is
too bad it's like people got addicted to
being lazy especially covid didn't help
people were like you know what this is
this is fun I don't have to do anything
I stay at my house and a habit a normal
habit creates itself in four days if you
do something for four days you keep
drinking you keep drinking like it's
gonna keep going you know what I mean so
you got to break break that habit we're
lazy and Reliant and relying yeah and
then like Mario hit like last week Pat
from my show for the Vincent o'shana
show Mario's like yeah we're gonna we
all agree we're coming in Saturday and
I'm normally you know Comedians and that
we're Monday through Friday but if I
felt like holy [__] in here on a
Saturday and it pays off when you see
the product of what you're doing on that
extra day you know what I mean you know
you know what I do on Saturdays I'll
bring the kids to the office
and it becomes an opportunity for me to
spend some time with them and then I'll
explain to them why I'm in the office
and say hey Daddy why do we have to go
to the office I'll say because if you
want to have an edge over your
competitors you got to do things they
don't want to do and they're like okay
that makes sense so then I'll see Dylan
stays practice after practice two hour
practice is over with you still for
another hour Dylan can ask you why
you're staying for another hour daddy if
you want to have an edge over your
competitive
bingo bingo there you go FY thanks to
Facebook and Instagram we got Dylan's
Instagram account back uh Dylan lost his
Instagram account because when I was
posting age I put his real age they said
bam
but they helped out which was kind of
good to get his account back Dylan says
that but anyways these are principles
that we're talking about next Walmart it
says 65 of stores
will be serviced by automation within
three years by the way this is a real
concern this is actually something that
ought to be a concern Walmart plans to
automate 65 of its stores within the
next 30 Years in order to speed up it's
uh or e-commerce fulfillment center the
move follows the announcement of laying
off 2000 employees who fulfill online
orders Walmart aims to move around 55 of
packages that it processes through its
fulfillment uh centers through automated
facilities by January 2026 which is
expected to improve unit cost averages
by about 20 percent the company's
investment in automation technology is
part of it's a more than 15 billion
dollar Capital spending budget this year
this this increased efficiency will
support better Inventory management and
Walmart's rapidly grown e-commerce
business Walmart hiked its minimum wage
earlier this year across the country
surpassing 1750 which were expected to
be reflected in March 2nd paychecks Tom
there's a cause of here ladies and
gentlemen and so you got Bernie Sanders
out there trying to raise the minimum
wage wage the minimum wage so how did
Walmart respond first of all they said
for the people that are working well in
our stores that that are doing well
we're going to move you up to 1750.
there's also a thing about Walmart was
actually paying uh some education
reimbursements when those people wanted
to go and take some courses but then on
the other side of it the other side of
the board meeting went like this look
uh the stock market is an angry beast
and we gotta feed it and we have to feed
it profits and a thing called the p e
ratio
how much we got
um we got 30 billion dollars in cash
what if we take 15 billion of it and we
invest in automation so we can keep the
best people at 17 bucks an hour but we
can compete with Amazon that's
automating and doing Amazon Prime and
you can click on there and you can get a
tube of toothpaste and an hour to your
front door I don't need instacart Amazon
Prime have you noticed that some things
they'll deliver like in two hours if you
order it now it'll be at your front door
in two hours and there it is and so
they're competing so there's three
angles here the first angle is beware of
capitalists if you put them in the
corner they're going to invent their way
out rule one never screw with real
capitalists and entrepreneurs rule two
you know what if you're gonna force me
to pay people more I only want the best
people and so you better be the best
otherwise you're not going to be here in
rule three competition brings out an
assortment of things that ultimately are
going to be good to Consumers because
you know what's going to happen here on
one side you could look at Labor and say
oh my gosh my gosh my gosh on the other
side you know what I see I see Walmart
competing with Amazon so that people get
efficient low-cost Consumer Staples at a
time when inflation is up so I look at
the other side and say hey there's going
to be an Amazon and a Walmart competing
so that people on average middle
American incomes can afford to get
things in a face of inflation and I
think that's important but that's what I
see here I see about three things moving
around you know I'll tell you one thing
that we learned in the last literally a
year maybe two years and when we had
Andrew Yang sitting right here where
Vinnie's sitting right there and this is
after five trillion dollars was printed
of stimi money and he was the biggest
proponent of universal basic income Ubi
that was his whole message uh when he
ran for uh the presidency in 2016. and
um was that was that 2020 whenever he
was running president okay I think it
was 16.
um no 20. and Pat said well make the
case for Ubi now Mr Yang he's like we
just gave out everybody money how we
doing and and you know he kind of
eloquently skirted well you know Ubi
it's just like it doesn't hold water
yeah like this [__] don't work yeah just
printing of the money and giving people
money to sit around and do nothing
doesn't work so uh I guess the point is
companies are gonna have to figure it
out employees are gonna have to figure
it out the the days of maybe Ubi is a
thing maybe just giving stimmy checks is
the thing I think we've proven during
covid this is not going to be beneficial
for the economy
is Walmart bad now or like I like other
robots there when I read automation I go
so wait are ai's taking over our jobs
because I said it was coming
so okay that was a good commentary here
by the way let's go let's go to uh let's
go to our friends uh let's do a quick
politics story man we can't let this go
without giving Nancy Pelosi shout out so
Pelosi event turns chaotic yes when
anti-war protesters say she belongs in
depths of Hell war criminal when you
start hearing people calling Democrats
war criminals I mean were they not the
anti-war party now it's like they are
the pro 100 war party it's confusing a
lot of different people let me read this
article to you
um which pages on page 400. okay
that's an inside joke for all right so
former Hospitality was Heckle that my
Intel were protesters during the City
University in New York even with
hecklers Colin or war criminal saddle
drunk oh one protester shouted you know
Pelosi that's a very good place for you
in the depths of hell because so for
some reason you have a very bad
Obsession of getting us into War and why
is it that you did not admit that there
were no weapons of mass destruction in
Iraq one protester yelled you lied to us
you light us into a war in Iraq you got
us into invasion of Afghanistan now over
90 of those people are impoverished and
dying why don't you tell the truth about
North stream why did we destroy
Nordstrom can you play the clip by the
way it's somewhere else if you haven't
it's amazing watch this see that's a
very good place for you in the depths of
hell because there's so many
[Applause]
of getting us into war
why is it that you did not admit that
there were dummies there were no wnds in
Iraq
and are dying she's not lying Orange
Vinnie what do you think about it
I'm proud of somebody like and then
watch one more person's coming one more
person Pat that is brave I respect these
people watch
there he is
[Music]
you're what you're a sad old drunk
yes
on purpose and look at that aren't you
supposed to be part of the indictment
tomorrow yes you're a warrant Criminal
by Death
Pelosi you got some nerve is that why
you're here in Manhattan wow is that why
[Music]
Hillary's on stage too notice how nobody
said Hillary Hillary was questioning her
wasn't she that's another clan
Paul Krugman no no the thumbnail had uh
Hillary on the left I was like is there
a difference yeah no no who's on the
left that's Paul Krugman who's to the
left Pelosi thought my bad I thought
Hillary was up there as well I didn't
know it was just them true but anyway
Pat I I love as a veteran too I love
when there's moments like this where
people oh yeah there's nobody else uh
the thumbnail had it it's just we need
more people like this oh standing up
because mind you you see this audience
this look at look at these these
libtards he's standing up yelling and
they they won't even let you say your
piece because it's true it's true all
the Wars all the all the Iraq and module
I'm going back to Bush for all these
anybody that got us into these words uh
the accountability zero accountability
how is bush bush Rumsfeld I mean Cheney
uh none of them got in trouble none of
them got their their held to the fire we
went to war because there was weapons of
mass destruction in Iraq we didn't find
them so what'd they do Pat they changed
the name of the war to what was it Iraqi
enduring Freedom or something and nobody
ever pays the price yeah operation
enduring freedom and yeah because you
just changed the name because we're
already there and we couldn't find
anything because they knew it wasn't
it's branding we'll make it sound better
yeah no of course but then now and then
now you have a an ex-president who who
hooked up with a porn star if that's
what you want to call her and that that
that person gets arrested and and goes
to jail I talk about me you're talking
about no I'm talking about Trump Bill
okay I'm not throwing Macho but it's
just it's just those type of moments
make me happy that people have the balls
to stand up and yell at them which it
ain't gonna do anything but I'm I'm a
I'm a little confused okay okay I'm just
a little confused by this because we can
make a list of all the wrongdoings that
Nancy Pelosi has done okay granted I'm
not here to defend Nancy Pelosi at all
but on my list of things that I would be
upset with Nancy Pelosi about the Iraq
war is not on the top of the list
because we this is after what 2003
Afghanistan was a 102 and then we went
into Iraq in 03 okay Rob fact check the
[__] out of me right now I'm sure that I
don't think Nancy Pelosi became speaker
of the house until 2007 2008 right
before Obama became elected fact check
well she was in politics
but she's not the person she's not the
tip of the spear what year Rob
uh 2007. okay all right so five years
after all this went down now you're
gonna come after her again I'm not
defending Pelosi yeah these people are
angry they're upset they want
accountability God bless them and they
deserve it but I just I don't it's not
adding up to me the war criminal thing
corrupt ridiculous absurd crazy nervous
Nancy drunk drunk all totally acceptable
yeah War Monger okay by the way I don't
even know about the nor nobody's proven
with Nordstrom too whether it was
Russians ukrainians America or us we
don't know us
again I'm not defending Nancy here I I
empathize with these people they're
upset about a whole host of [__] that's
going on in San Francisco California I'd
be out there
getting crazy too I just don't know if
this specific
um meltdown is actually that warranted I
think it shows that there's some
underlying tensions about her I think
that's the long and short of X I agree
with you it's like wait a minute what
are you actually talking about and you
could pick apart the actual things
they're saying but I think what it says
underneath there is that there's a lot
more dissatisfaction with Nancy Pelosi
than the media and her and her careful
branding spin but I agree with you what
are you talking about factually we can
break this down say number one you're
rude number one it's disrespectful other
citizens are coming here to hear
something
um and this and so we should actually
feel sorry for the Pelosi's because
getting hammered is is uh it's just a
problem for that and yeah Paul gets
hammered well different kind of
hammering but and then Nancy's getting
hammered you know so the poor Pelosi's
they're just dealing with the hammer
this year so why don't we just leave
them alone and Vinnie brings up a good
point if I mean listen if there's
anybody that this if you're angry about
this we're this direction this heat
should be headed it's the Bush
George W bush Dick Cheney Donald
Rumsfeld the list goes on yeah and
believe me those guys have heard it for
years uh we had uh Ari Fleischer here
yeah Ari Fleischer was the uh press
secretary for Bush during 9 11 yeah
Afghanistan Iraq and he even said listen
this is something that I have to wear
for the rest of my life when we said
they have weapons of mass destruction
and he had to take that out and I think
Ari Fleischer is a capable informed
smart dude and I even asked him about
that on the podcast Pat you remember
he's like yeah I got I have no response
we [__] up yeah but Adam that cost
America trillions of dollars
in The Halliburton strategic Revenue
plan I mean yeah yeah rock war the
military industrial Oklahoma here's my
thing but Adam I'm not happy with just
taking the L you need to take his ass to
jail because they like hold on we're not
talking about uh who should go to jail
everybody that signed on and said we are
going to Iraq because they have this and
we killed over a million million women
children so we ruined that going there
from Iraq to Afghanistan to everything
started because of that from 9 11 to
that and no who who has gone to jail for
killing all those people because that's
like saying all right guys we're gonna
go and shoot up Tom's house because Tom
stole this from us and we go there we
shoot up town we shoot the whole thing
and then we're like oh [__] Tom didn't
steal it now what we just get to make an
Ella just walk away [__] I think you
bring up a good point because I think
whether it's what you're saying right
now whether that's that's those angry
protesters whether it's going on what's
happening in the banking system right
now people want accountability 100 and
the problem is the people at the top
very rarely are held accountable whether
it's Bush whether it's freaking fauci
whoever it is and I think a lot of the
anger especially from the right is like
okay so nobody's held accountable but
Donald Trump pays a [__] porn star
some hush money and now he's held
accountable this is [__] and I
understand people's frustration because
yeah
what's what's you know the the I saw a
clip the other day a guy says okay so
Tate Goes to Jail gets arrested
when everything is allegedly there's not
no charge or nothing yet right Trump
goes and is being indicted and they 34
different counts it's like oh well we
have something bigger but we have
something bigger okay you made this guy
fly out because you wanted that image
and you allowed photographers to get in
there even though they're not it's
supposed to be a drawing that's how it
typically is done but you're a lot of
photographers to get in there and then
he goes into all these other people and
he says but how many people got arrested
for going to the Epstein Islands none
zero how's that possible why are we not
investigating that list yep who's being
protected who's not that alone
you know what I like about uh Bill Maher
Bill Maher is not a Democrat who defends
Democrats Bill Maher is a liberal who is
now going against the establishment he's
not going against Republicans or dams he
just can't stand the establishment is
who is pushing back on right well the
establishment is hiding what happened to
Epstein well what happened there you
have access to it you have the
information can we find out
can we find out what happened there or
is that a crew that is all protecting
each other 100 you know attacking each
other
that's the part where you start kind of
wondering there has to be something
that's been hidden I don't know who I
asked when I said do you think that'll
ever come out he says it'll never come
out who was sitting here that said it'll
never come out oh yeah was it oh Charlie
Kirk no we did it at the assistant never
come out never but but I think in about
30 years they're gonna do a movie when
you and I are in our 70s we're gonna go
to movies and we're going to sit there
we're going to say that's crazy we live
through that and nothing happened it
took 30 years for us to see what
happened there's somebody will make the
movie 100 now like somebody's got the
kahunas to make that konas to make that
movie sooner rather than 30 years from
now because a lot of these people that
are part of that are about to die in the
next 10 or 15. yeah but but think about
the secrecy is not to cut you off time
think about like the like for the JFK
thing we all we're not stupid we all
know what happened the CIA just recently
said that they all had you know they had
a hand in it that that big lie what do
you mean that 100 something like that
JFK assassination look how long they've
held the secret like nobody's really
come for him like yeah I know you stay
quiet that Epstein Island bro they are
just they know listen keep your mouth
shut or something's gonna happen to you
that's it they're good and then actually
if you go in Dallas down to this uh to
The Book Depository and you can go up
there to the sixth floor and you can
take a tour and there's this one area
that talks about you know uh
conspiracies and all it says is that
there have been many many conspiracy
theories over the years
and the only thing that they do there is
they let you put on headphones and you
can listen and they tell you would 98
certainty you are going to hear not an
echo but four shots and the thing was
Oswald fired 3 or the book and so after
this many years there's a little glimpse
of Truth they say now we don't know who
did it or where it came from but we can
conclusively say from these Police
radios there were four shots and it's
interesting now
you're right enough years go by and the
truth is going to come out because you
can go down there and there's no longer
that whole exhibit down there is not
Oswald acted alone he shot fired three
times hit Connolly hit Kennedy in the
neck then Kennedy in the head and that's
that magic bullet thank you thank you
very much cue Lyndon Johnson yeah right
that no no they you can go down and
listen to it and they'll say there were
four shots fired and they're saying by
who well we don't know and there's a lot
of theories as to who fired up but there
were four shots you know if only four
but here we are 50 years later suddenly
that is a that is that exhibit is
operated by the government as a
historical location and you pay six
dollars and go up and take a tour so
long enough that all comes out
uh it's it's it's pretty by the way did
you guys see what happened with Riley
Gaines this last weekend yeah just
yesterday or two days ago uh can you go
to the Riley game story uh a trans
activist uh uh uh do you have it or no
okay she was hit multiple times by a guy
in a dress terrified Riley Gaines is
ambushed by screaming trans activists
who physically attacked her after
swimming champion delivered speech on
saving women's sports at San Francisco
State University which by the way they
have a great baseball program there so
let me say a terrified against a forced
to Bar barricade herself into a room at
San Francisco State University campus
after last night a group of activists
ambushed her gains a husband Louisa
Barker said he had brief conversations
with his wife while she was locked in
the room for nearly three hours she told
me she was hit multiple times by a guy
in a dress I was shaking it made me that
mad it makes me sick to feel so helpless
about it do you have a video on this or
no is there a video to see what happened
or no is that the video can you play it
um
dude look at how angry they're getting
huh
[Applause]
wow
now mind you Pat you know that the white
house uh Korean Jean-Pierre on Thursday
was like she praised Fierce kids who are
transgender for ability to fight back
they're telling them like hey fight back
mind you that that shooter that trans
shooter and she didn't say that I swear
to God she did on Thursday she said it
she said she had the word she said
Fierce kids who are transgender for the
ability to fight back and not only tone
death when the Nashville shooting
happened uh the what was it two days
later or two or three days later Tom
they did a trans visibility day and they
were saying hey guys the trans Community
is under attack no no time out a trans
just shot and killed three kids and told
like what the hell are we what are we
talking about like you play this
with the enactment of a new law in
Indiana 14 states have now banned gender
affirming Health Care while some of
these laws are currently blocked by
courts this is a dangerous a dangerous
attack on the rights of parents to make
the best health care decisions for their
own kids
according to the Human Rights Campaign
more than 50 percent of transgender
youth in the U.S which is estimated to
be more than 150 000 kids live in States
in which transgender youth have lost
access to or at risk of losing access to
gender affirming care
look this is awful news let's be very
clear about that
lgbtq I plus kids are resilient they are
Fierce they fight back yeah they're not
going anywhere yeah and we have their
back this Administration has their back
we are so proud of the kids across this
country who have organized protest and
school walkouts to tell the politicians
in their states to stop this legislative
bully you know Pat like can you guys
explain to me they're they're you know
why they're upset you know why they're
upset because we're not letting them
these states
mess up their children's bodies and chop
off their their genitalia what is the
obsession with kids Pat can you please
explain like make me understand why
that's what they're pushing for the
states that are Banning that that
transition for kids that haven't even
developed in their minds and I've said
it before on this podcast what is the
obsession with children is it because
all that gender affirm and Care is
that's big Pharma because is it because
it's money involved Pat or is it because
those those people can't have kids and
they want the population could somebody
explain it to me I don't get it I don't
understand and now you're telling these
people Hey listen get mad get pissed off
be fierce stand up like I don't get it
yeah and I'm confused I'm very confused
yeah you know you know again for me uh
I'd like to believe Common Sense
prevails
you know I'd like to believe we come to
our senses I'd like to believe you know
that bad policies will eventually get
exposed right but I also know in a
situation like this I can't show that
Meme enough can you go to the pbd
podcast meaning that one meme about you
know the parents no to this no to that
no to that no to this if you can pull
that up just go to Twitter to show that
but this meme honestly has to be shown
so many times for people to
keep repeating this statement to people
for others to realize you know that this
is common sense keep going down keep it
right there you know can you drive a car
no can you pick your bedtime no can you
drink a beer no can you vote no can you
cut off your sex organs and take
hormones yes oh my God this doesn't make
any
sense whatsoever and even by the way
again this whole concept of the West
takes criticism and other people's
criticism of the West
I had a guy yesterday came up to me who
was at the uh the podcast showing we had
a very good conversation ticket he's a
Muslim and say Pat can I talk to you I
love everything you're saying he says
but man you you gotta you gotta have a
Muslim on to kind of hear our
perspective I'm not an extremist trust
me there's extremism in Muslim I
understand what you're saying but man
there's a lot of us that are good I'm
like dude in our company in the
insurance company our Muslim Community
in the insurance company is growing and
we have a couple people in the company
freaking amazing amazing people like
truly you'll love them there's amazing
amazing people right well you can sit
down and have a conversation
the the fear becomes well you know a
Muslim is growing Christianity is you
know not growing and how you're
competing and then you listen to their
argument this is not about Prophet do
you know Prophet Muhammad married this
big girl I'm not having that debate
that's not the conversation I'm having
in this context I will tell you one is
compromising their values the other's
not okay one is saying don't worry about
it cut off your dangling you're only
seven years old the other one's saying
what the hell are you talking about get
the hell back in your room say that one
more time so you're like oh my God
you're such an extreme parent you don't
say let her do whatever she wants to do
why are you being on top of it the way
you are compromising the other one is
saying I'm the freaking father I'm the
freaking mother you know what is
starting to happen here's what's going
to happen
I remember I'm leading my uh sales
organization and I'm working with folks
and my style was hey what else can I do
to you what else can I do to help you
can I make some calls for you can I go
run some appointments with you can I do
this I want to help and I'm like damn
none of this [__] is working I'm 25
years old I'll never forget this meeting
I had Mario tells a story better than I
do I'm 25 years old I come in I had a
long weekend Sunday I'm in my office I'm
like I'm busting my ass I'm freaking
doing my best and nothing is happening
this is so annoying
and I sat and I said I got a bunch of 18
19 year olds who were hooking up every
day I walked into the office on Sundays
they're hooking up because they don't
have a place to go hook up they're
they're literally in the parking lot
they're walking I'm like okay that guy's
hooked up with that person I know
everybody that would walk in yeah
eventually I'm like no here's what we're
gonna do I come in Monday morning I say
stand up if you're under 25 years old
they stood up if you stay standing if
you're married if you're single stand it
stay stand if you have no kids no kids I
said get out
what do you mean get out
what do you mean get out I'm not working
with you guys anymore kid I go to a
different company or a different office
I'm not working with you Mario's in the
room I said I'm gonna give you five
minutes get out I'm not dealing with any
of your [__] anymore get out
come on guys oh well you do something
what happened to the path that's I say
I'm telling you I don't like that pad
that pad is pissing me off there's a new
pad in town okay get out one guy gets up
he gets out the girl follows him the
girl's the girl that he was hooking up
with so phones I know all the stuff yeah
yeah then the next guy gets up and gets
on next guy I said get out so I'm
looking I'm already get out I'm not
getting out George get out not getting
out get out I'm not getting out 20
people walk out five people stick around
Mario's Mario one guy George we paid
George one and a half million dollars
last year he's now 35 years old married
just bought a three million dollar house
in freaking Austin he's having a great
time in his life okay Cindy is a rock
star what she's doing her family she
makes 600 Grand years she's 34 35. she's
from Palmdale both of these guys are
from Palmdale the people that stuck
around became leaders but I went from
hey I this that I'm like no get your ass
up run appointments do this do that or
else this is not the office for you now
was it a little extreme yes did I need
to learn to bring it back down at 26 27
28 did I learn yes that came with
maturity you know what Muslims are doing
they're Christians are not Muslims are
saying get your ass out of bed and go do
this no we don't stand up for this let
Americans do this stuff this is not us I
don't know what the hell you're talking
about being so you know what is it
accommodating to everybody stop trying
to please everybody Christians some of
your values are supposed to piss people
off it's not supposed to get everybody
to say this makes sense there is a part
of it that's a little bit extreme in
high standards versus you know no no no
it's okay no no no it's okay to me the
no no no it's okay is anybody can come
to church I I listen I went to church
I'm sitting there talking to Grandma do
you realize what I just did this weekend
you want me at the church this Sunday do
you really want to know what I did if I
tell you the story you're going to get
uncomfortable let me tell you what I did
no no you don't need to tell us because
I'm telling you you don't want me at the
church yeah I'm not and then I went and
sitting all the way in the back I'm like
this guy's probably a distance then I
start criticizing seeing all this stuff
right I'm like but I'm going to come
back next Sunday because he's got good
jokes so I come back next Sunday do you
realize I just came back every Sunday
for a year and a half just because the
guy was funny and I like the way he told
stories then eventually I you know do
what I do my life things change
but we you Tom myself all of us in here
deep down inside you know what we deep
down inside love and we know we need
even though we fight it strong
leadership 100 we need it
you need it America needs it kids need
it the West if the criticism is a fair
criticism to give the West you're
getting soft 100 and you're compromising
your values and it's a pathetic weak
move that's going to hurt you long term
it ain't too late yet to go back to the
same old standards to and just say what
the hell are you talking about cutting
these things off what do you mean no no
this is not acceptable you cannot do
things like this so my hopes
is that we're going to eventually get
our heads out of our asses and realize
Common Sense prevails and bad policies
get exposed a lot of them are starting
to get exposed and we're going to get
back to some normal normality but it's
only going to happen with a strong
leader that's going to come and knock
some Senses Into the West because the
West is a little bit drunk right now
they're high they're taking one too many
sleeping pills they're a little bit too
soft they're compromising and they they
need to realize we've led the world
we have set the tone to the world U.S
has set the tone to everybody else they
follow Us's lead not the other way
around now we're following other
people's leads time out yeah the hell
are we doing here so and uh I don't know
I mean I I'm in America because I love
what America stood for not what
America's standing for today what
America stood for is why I came to
America while I love this place some of
the [__] we're standing for today I
don't stand for that stuff well I think
the a this comes down to the soft
parents number one and number two all
this started happening all this started
happening I think a generation or two
pet after mine Adam were disciplining
your kids like you were saying not
beating them people always take that out
of context disciplining your kids became
taboo it became don't touch that hey hey
little hey don't touch that to now the
kids are like I could oh you're not
gonna do anything Jimmy don't remember
we told you so now Jimmy's going you
know what I'm gonna I'm gonna become a
girl and you can't do anything about it
dad there's no hope and then what do you
say to people that they're like okay now
these parents are going to the schools
because the school is a big part of it
but then when you try to speak up in the
school they're labeling you uh domestic
terrorists like there's no there's no
hope like I feel you're love your
optimism Pat but I don't think and then
when the White House is standing up
there in front of you saying hey let let
us let the system take your your you
know hormone therapy for your kids and
and dude it's there's no winning for the
parents these kids have no hope I don't
I don't think the quality of being
helpless or feeling like you've lost
hope is a good strategy ever uh because
you know kind of like same thing I said
to Rudy yesterday when Rudy and I had a
big back and forth I don't know how long
for like 20 minutes I'm like this whole
thing about you know well they cheated
they did something like honestly I can't
stand it when my kids when they lose and
Dylan or chico or something they cheated
I'm like listen I don't care if they
cheated be better because I can cheat
all I want if I play one-on-one against
Kobe he's still going to beat me I can
cheat all I want if I play against
Jordan he's still going to beat me it
doesn't matter the great ones you can
cheat and they're still gonna whoop your
ass right so for me this this this
concept of when you say they cheated the
other side it doesn't want to show up
because in their mind they're thinking
oh they're going to cheat anyway so
we're going to lose why should I even
show up and vote no stop saying that
just show up let's show up more get more
people to Rally have a party get
thousands of people to go with you to
vote be a better rallyer at getting
people to show up on vote so for me I
think the moment hope is gone people
don't want to put the energy to fight
because they're thinking they're
hopeless they're hopeless we're not
historically leaders have risen
historically they rise up till today
I saw something the other day was so
freaking emotional I'd love to play it
because it plays a song I love a lot by
Hillsong Oceans and it's a clip of a guy
I want to give it to you rob without you
playing the music the music makes the
video so much more freaking emotional
but I'm gonna give it to you anyways and
I want you just Rob do me a favor try to
do without playing the music so this
video stays on it's it's so freaking
heartbreaking when you watch this but at
the end you have to respect mankind
because we freaking care
mankind cares mankind I'm getting the
chills just thinking about this right
Goosebumps dude we we love people man we
don't like bullies and scumbags we're
willing to stand up and give hope to
other people here's a guy here in this
video that's pouring Benzene or gas on
top of them to commit suicide and watch
what happens at the end I just want you
to see and this is real he's really just
watch this watch this right now in the
middle of it everybody's smelling it
they're stepping away he's taking a
lighter out everyone starts running look
these guys are the pansies they're
running but Watch What Happens watch
what she does that's what I'm talking
about she takes the lighter away from
him like you can't kill yourself bro you
can't give up life is worth it you're
going through a tough time this message
is America
This Is Us
we have to fight for each other we have
to tell each other listen bro I don't
know what the [__] are you thinking
right now you've lost your mind
you don't sound right you don't sound
reasonable think about your kids think
about the future think about each other
what are you doing to yourself America
if if we come from that place and we
look at each other and we say dude come
on snap out of it go take a damn cold
shower you're better than this I had a
guy that was working for me every every
day for a month he knows who he is every
day for a month we would go to this
lunch place I won't even say the place
because some people are going to try to
calculate exactly who it was
every day at lunch he was talking about
suicide
every day and I would sit there I'm like
dude I'm telling you bro just trust me
this shit's not going to last this long
it's gonna suck for two years
I'm telling you good things are around
the corner bro what do you taught this
pad what is life worth I'm like I'm
telling you and by the way this is not
the guy that wants attention this is a
guy that was a guy that doesn't want
attention he's not saying this to
everybody he's just telling me this
talking to me like a brother do you know
how he's doing today freaking amazing
life so happy when I saw him we saw each
other we gave each other a hug and you
know the conversation was like you know
when you look at somebody in the eyes
and you know that they know that you
know that they know and you like you cry
yeah without saying anything yeah that's
this America changed my life
America's changed so many people's lives
we need to go back to selling how
freaking amazing of a concept this was
and can be but we cannot just give up
hope and be helpless thinking we can't
do anything about it okay look one thing
I know about myself I'm a sinner at the
highest level I'm perfect I've done some
stupid [__] in my life I've done I've
said stuff I've done this I've done that
I've done this I don't see myself as a
guy that's perfect we can't have a
standard of perfection right now
nobody's perfect nobody knows it all
none of us no matter how much money you
got no matter how good you look no
matter how many followers you got nobody
cares we all have flaws all of us we
have to strive to get better we have to
strive to get our arguments to be better
we have to strive to become better
fathers better husbands better wives
better Brothers better sisters better
contributors to society where you're
sitting there debating the argument of
four days a week and you actually saying
that's a good argument that's a selfish
argument to me because you have talent
to give to the rest of us God gave you
certain Talent where if you do something
with your talents we're going to benefit
from it what a selfish position to only
put four hours four week into it why
don't you contribute just like we're
doing our best to contribute let's
collectively work together I think those
are the arguments that need to be
delivered in a better way for people to
say
damn that kind of does make sense what
am I doing but that video I saw man I
watched that video I'm going to give it
to you guys afterwards to what because
you're going to walk we'll watch it
afterwards with music on watch how
you'll feel it okay you'll see it in a
very different way anyways sorry about
the rent I just said you know this
really you triggered me with it oh it's
all good number one I love when Pat goes
off on this this is coming it's not it's
not no script yeah you're not reading no
speech this is from the heart and I'll
just kind of maybe try to put a a ribbon
on this you know this conversation
started with Vinnie bringing up the
transgender or speaking out against
transgender what's the swimmer's name
Riley game Riley games you know she's
famous because she was the one competing
against this Leah Thomas person yeah
okay that's how she became to notoriety
and you know what I'm thinking about as
you're saying this and you're saying
this and you're saying this and I'll
keep revisiting this well is that
decline in American values that we just
talked about the other day Okay in
patriotism in community involvement in
religion in wanting kids the only thing
that did go up was wanting money and I
think what you're talking about is can
we just get back to normal and that's
why this girl Riley Gaines is saying hey
I'm a woman yeah I lost the race to this
dude over here yeah okay and now I want
to speak out and tell my story and now
I'm getting shamed because I'm a woman
and I what happened to the feminism
thing can I believe what happened with
that and I think what Pat's saying is
that what he did in that office what he
does with these kids is I'm going to
tell you what you need to hear not what
you want to hear I'm not going to lower
my standards and I think what we're
seeing is that America is lowering our
standards and accepting
nonsensical things to be today's reality
and here I'm going to call out [__]
Joe Biden for a second right now okay
because I'm gonna call if I'm gonna call
out Trump I'm also going to call out
Biden so Biden says the other day this
is after the shooting he says quote
unquote transgender people shape our
nation's soul in official Proclamation
let me just read this real quick go
ahead he issued an official Proclamation
declaring the transgender American shape
our nation's soul and establish an
American holiday relating to this group
you reissued this on March 31st
transgender American shape our nation so
proudly serving in the military curing
deadly diseases holding elected office
running thriving businesses fighting for
justice raising families and much more
all right listen uh Joe Biden uh
transgender people are 0.5 of 1 of our
nation yeah okay do they deserve to be
treated like human beings do they
deserve to be of course respect sure but
who shapes our nation so goals our
families our people with kids or people
that have grandparents and aunts and
uncles and families and kids and
American family values that is our
nation's Soul yeah okay transgenders
might be a sliver of what's going on
here but they are not the ones shaping
no our nation's soul I agree and this
pandering to the woke left so they can
[__] get 0.5 of people's votes yeah
is nonsensical to me 100 and I totally
understand to revisit this exactly why
Riley Gaines is like hey uh just a
female swim over here trying to compete
against women yeah and you got this dude
over here who's six five Lurch yeah
beating me it's like this doesn't make
sense any sense it's a back to back
credit this [__] just doesn't add up
yeah and you made it I mean made a great
Point Adam where are all and I'm being
genuine I'm calling them out we're all
the genuine feminists the Lena uh Dunham
Alyssa Milano the Beyonce's all the
where are you at you have like it you
morons it doesn't bother you that like
like for instance look at this picture
right here yeah yeah let me I mean
you're like you know how they say A
picture says a thousand words like
that's just look at the picture yeah
like the lady on the left wink wink yeah
it's so absurd they shared a locker room
all these folks did and that guy still
had equipment so he was still packing
heat yeah he has yeah unbelievable and
Tom Tom you have children Pat you have
children let me ask you a question you
guys have Rob try to zoom in
volleyball volleyball you guys have you
have children Pat you have a daughter
Tom you have daughters so Pat what how
do you feel what do you do you have a
daughter right Santa you have your
daughter date she she works her whole
childhood you have her in swimming she
busts her ass she's honing her crap
she's sacrificing going out with her
friends no movies no boyfriend her
entire youth is it's she sacrificed to
be the best swimmer then she's about to
go to college and loses a scholarship
her place because there's a dude with
testicles that wants to be in there and
nobody says anything people are praising
them what do you do as a father what's
your reaction what do you do oh you're
gonna have to speak up and say something
about it and and defend your daughter
who's been training hard and you know
going do your part to get involved on a
board and have a voice and call the
people out you can't sit on the
sidelines be quiet about it you have to
create a voice and say something about
it and defend your daughter because this
is demoralizing to your daughter that's
this is demo if you don't have that
conversation with her this is very
demoralizing it's surprising that the
feminists are are defending this they
and they're oh they're quiet but I but
but I'm so like for me Tom you wanted to
say something you have two girls
yourself as well so what would you say
about what Vinnie just said right there
so I think I
I look at it and I've been quiet for a
few minutes here uh intentionally I step
back and I look at it and I say okay
there is a new
entitlement group out there there is a
new marginalized group and it's called
trans and the media will cancel you cost
you your job cost you your reputation
and attack you if you go against the
narrative that trans is a new
marginalized discriminated against
groups so you have true feminists that
fought like hell for Title IX Title Nine
you know in college sports said that
women's college sports should get the
same funding and opportunity as men
college sports thank you very much and
that there were some sports that will be
unique to men football and there are
going to be some sports that were unique
to women ballet and dance you know
ballet there's dance but there's you
know what I'm talking about so number
one that's where it started right now
you have I haven't spoken to any college
coach I've ever seen I've asked this
question and I said should we should we
respect
that for whatever reason they are
declaring themselves trans well yeah
that's surrendered okay but if they're
gonna say that and a male is going to
say I identify as female uh okay but but
still if we run a blood test and
everything you got your testosterone
everything like this I'll tell you what
we fought like heck for Title IX to give
women the opportunity all you men that
want to compete in division two of men
you compete against yourselves
transcompete against trans leave natural
men or what they call CIS men and leave
CIS women to themselves and let the
trans compete against trans because it
is not equal it says Rob there is a an
article
and this is serious because there is
different physiological things look at
the size of the swimmers size 13 feet
find me a woman with size 13 feet you'll
find one in the USA female swimmer with
a size 13 foot men they're all size 13
14 and 15 and they have longer arms they
are mechanically Superior in the water
they're just mechanically Superior now
look at this trans high school
volleyball player male who wanted to be
known as a female uses a vicious Spike
which hindered the female opponent in a
highlight reel and so then guess what
they did here there's North Carolina
right North Carolina said stop scroll
down Rob trans
trans men cannot compete with women
because of the difference in size and
strength
let's let trans compete against trans
women over here trans over here men over
here this guy knocked her freaking out
he knocked her out this is a man
so you're saying have a trans League
Time watch this one
is that a guy
no they're about to there's another clip
apparently that girl to the left is Gap
is about to get oh oh dude this cat is
oh that's a guy that's a guy that's a
dude that's right they're all the guys
got it nuts and all ladies and gentlemen
wow
yeah well I'll say one thing about this
the speed that they've looked at it the
speed off the spike and the the level of
of jumping was different and so how can
you say so what do I say first of all I
see it as a form of cheating I see it
absolutely it's affordable cheating of
using the trans excuse to go win the
NCAA tournament Leah I'm talking to you
first second the NCAA after all these
years of Title IX we're completely
turning our backs on all the progress we
made for women let the trans compete as
trans let women compete as women let men
compete as as men at the school's got
enough budgets they can have trans team
great otherwise go raise the money for
your team just like regular teams do and
I see it as a form of cheating and so
what do I do if my kids I talk to my
daughters there's going to be cheating
people are going to want to cheat don't
be one of them and don't be don't be
discouraged after the fact you're going
to be discouraged in the moment you're
going to feel ripped off you're going to
feel emotions you're going to feel
cheated you're going to feel robbed
you know Bailey's team for golf lost the
Texas state championship because one of
her players was baited into what's
called not moving a mark back on the
green baited on the last hole and it was
a two-stroke penalty and they lost by
one and I said you know what you have to
carry Bailey you have to carry the fact
that you won on the course all the
practice all the effort all the energy
all the dedication all the the things
winning your league winning your region
winning your District then winning your
region going there you won the Texas
State Golf Championship as a team that
you were baited now was the the penalty
was appropriate but you were that player
was baited and that's not right and they
all suffered the indignity of the
opposing coach saying I never saw it but
on the 17th and 18th green you had
Parents with camera phones all over the
place saying baloney that's you right
there what do you mean never saw it
those are your arms cross with your
coach visor quietly looking at your
player making a putt that's you yeah and
so listen
the cheating part of it it's gonna
happen in life don't let that be you
allow your emotions to come to the
surface because they're normal human
emotions not suppress your emotions I'll
just I'll just let my final thoughts
number one shout out to Bailey yeah
hello broker out there prediction time
so I guess I'd gone prediction okay uh
everything uh at the end of the day I
think there's going to be some sort of
come to Jesus jump the shark moment
where we're like we can't look past this
anymore and it's not going to be in
sports like swimming or volleyball or
tennis or golf or you're not competing
physically against the other person yeah
unfortunately the sad reality this is
gonna happen in a [__] boxing ring or
a wrestling match where some
trans Dude shows up and beats the living
[__] death out of some chick it's gonna
be a permanent and she's gonna get a
concussion brain hemorrhage die he might
rip her limbs off and beat her with her
limbs I don't know what kind of gorilla
[__] might happen by the way but
unfortunately that's what might happen
by the way you're you're absolutely
right okay so for me when when one of
our sales guys or sometimes the kids
come up with an idea that I know it's a
bad idea sometimes I let him do it and
I'll say okay yeah you know what go
ahead and do it good do it do it and see
what happens okay so they'll go and
they'll do it and then all of a sudden
they'll be like hey you know uh uh it
didn't work I'm like yeah yeah that's
good now you know it doesn't work so go
back to what does work instead of going
to sometimes you have to allow bad ideas
to take effects for us to eventually see
the data and say this didn't work before
we get into fed now I want to talk about
fed now before we wrap up we got eight
minutes left yeah a lot of you know when
people say Kobe Bryant's inspiration he
got his inspiration aspirations from who
who was the guy that
he wanted to be like Mike LeBron wanted
to be like who okay well maybe a magic
maybe you know some of those guys Tom
Brady wanted to be like who
you know we finally figured out who
Dylan Mulvaney wanted to be like who can
you please show this to us
[Laughter]
okay that's where oh my God now it all
makes sense oh my God
Inspirations
I know you know this Dylan Mulvaney
trans dude you know he doesn't have
boobs no no well no he no listen to me
he whatever I don't want whatever you
want to call him he is not only the
sponsored out the spokesperson of Bud
Light let me explain something to pissed
off Kelly uh the other day when she
heard it she is the the spokes person
for tampons yeah tampon set what uh try
to explain to me how would do because he
still has his his male parts am I am I
correct to assume that what is he using
no surgeries his name is still Dylan how
is tampon I what I I don't even know
what to say like well let's go to the
last story because we only got a couple
minutes so congratulations to him for
however magic he pulled to get that but
Rob can you pull up the story guys we
gotta do this in seven minutes because
we got Elite Mastermind so while you're
pulling this up I'll read the title The
santis and RFK Jr misconstrue Fett's
digital plans and warning of government
overreach now obviously NBC is defending
the FED now uh uh uh you know what
they've come out with so this this is
the Fed made digital dollar that they're
talking about here's what the scientists
had to say about this so Florida
Governor DeSantis alleged last week that
a Fed made digital U.S dollar would let
government block transactions like
buying a rifle or filling up with too
much gas
he added speaking at a Pennsylvania
conference on Saturday they're going to
try to impose an ESG agenda referring to
the private sector policy amid uh aimed
at the advancing environmental and
social and governance principles which
conservative lawmakers across the
country have been pushing to curb it is
seeding the power of our Financial
Freedom to Central to a central bank
which does not have our interest at
heart the Republican Governor has who
has been widely floated as a potential
primary rival to president Trump has
introduced legislation of Florida
seeking to ban the use of any fed issued
digital currency in the state and has
called on other states to do the same
the FED is re uh uh dying its fed now
initiative which aims to shorten the
time it takes for banks to send funds to
other banks for a planned July rollout
separately it has also been exploring
the possible quality of issuing a
digital version of the dollar that
households could readily use instead of
cash the central bank issue currency
would be using digital wallets offered
by the private sector including by
consumer leaders now Powell
said we haven't decided that this is
something that the financial system in
the country would want or need so that's
going to be very important that's what
Powell said okay and then the Santa's
comments came with endings of remarks of
anti-vaccine were activist Robert uh F
Kennedy they have to put it that way who
tweeted Wednesday that a Fed issued
currency would allow the government to
surveil all our Private Affairs
financial affairs enforce dollar limits
on our transactions restricting where
you can send money freeze your assets or
limit your spending or approve to
approved vendors if you fail to comply
we're arbitrary uh uh vaccine uh
mandates like it's another one at that
time when you see this what do you think
about this well I think about the danger
it poses to the nation's strippers
because
because that's where I saw Tom going if
it's if it's digital and it's on your
phone some guy is going to go in to a
strip club and I'm going to make it rain
in here and he's gonna be throwing his
phone and she could get hurt
no this what I think here I think
there's some truth to it that if the the
issue is it's not just a digital dollar
it's all the tracking now on one hand
they say well now then people can't
cheat on taxes and this and this and
this and I I think that there's you know
the whole concept the first of all what
they're talking about up above in that
digital systems that are all you know
aligned we have to take a look and step
back and look at convenience
for instance does anybody remember when
you had to look at the back of your ATM
card maybe when you're 18 years old and
the symbol had to be at an ATM that was
on the back of your card you remember
that oh is this your 7-Eleven plus
system oh I'm plus system with my Wells
Fargo card I can get money here well now
it's completely ubiquitous you can go to
any ATM and get money with your card
that's how the banking system got it
together so it made it convenient for
people to go get money wherever they
want to get money so part of this is
we're going to make it easy for the
banks to work with each other and
instantly transfer overnight that's not
a bad thing pay your car loan because
it'll be with a bank pay your credit
card it's with a bank that part is good
and then the um the ATM part of that
that I just described which is true
history that is a good helpful thing
moving it Forward what people are
worried about is if the government
through a digital currency also has the
ability to digitally track everything
and when you see what happened to you
may not like it but you see what
happened to Andrew Tate who had his
stripe turned off because stripe was
told turn him off wow and they turned
him off as part of a canceling effort
the danger is you can have canceling
efforts which has never happened except
for stripe Facebook Twitter Instagram
people getting canceled everywhere you
can't have a canceling effect out there
that part makes me very worried and this
happened imagine this this we heard this
story yesterday isn't it just random
that the cash app guy gets stabbed to
death and dies in San Francisco
we see the films and everything yeah
it's very weird though isn't it like
well it's not deep like that horrible
tragedy 100 and I don't hope to see one
thing or another but it appears to be a
random mugging killing and I hope it's
not something deep like that me neither
but it's this just to be clear we were
talking about Central Bank digital
currencies right cbdc's and I think the
the biggest concern that people have
with this is more government control and
now it's control not over your life just
now they're controlling your money it's
over and whether it's like your taxes
whether you didn't pay a parking ticket
they can freeze your assets oh you
didn't get vaccinated well time so we're
gonna we're gonna take your uh your
wages garnish your wages oh we're gonna
turn you off so we were talking
yesterday about the Patriot Act and
government surveillance and now this new
thing that just been rolled out less
than a month ago that Charlie Kirk was
talking about the restrict act it's and
we're also seeing what's happening with
the biggest concern with the banking
right now is the nationalization of
banks it's like oh no banks are certain
Banks Can't Fail now too big to fail
this nationalization of money now with
the Central Bank digital currencies I
think is a way bigger concern than
people understand this is not Bitcoin
this is not you know
just hey you know your money can't be
tracked there's it's decentralized
currency no this is centralized currency
Big Brother this is Big Brother coin
exactly so I think this is a big concern
my fear is that they're gonna Market it
in a way that it's like it's gonna make
life easier pay your taxes online do
everything online this is some big
brother [__] this is what happens in
China because in China don't they have
something called the social credit score
yes isn't that something I don't know if
Rob you can pull that up oh you said
something about she uh you got the jam
now like you you you don't do anything
that the government doesn't want you to
do it's jail time so here China
exactly the third trial this is this is
Russia can you read that out yeah so
China's social social credit system
gives individuals businesses and
government entities a credit score based
on their
trustworthiness a bad credit score will
have penalties like reduced access to
credit and fewer fewer business
opportunities
The Establishment The Establishment in
America loves seeing how China has such
control over its people that's their
hero to see hey how can we have more
control over our people so none of them
can come and push back with what we have
to say and what our agenda is anyways
it's obviously a uh idea that a lot of
people are concerned about and it makes
sense why you ought to be concerned
about something like this let free
market do it because you can always have
a choice to go somewhere somewhere else
if they do it they can control you in
ways free market cannot anyways great
podcast today great podcast yesterday uh
again for some of you guys that are
watching this you want to be the first
to know we're about to make three major
announcements in the next four weeks one
of them is going to be massive I think
one is bigger than the other one so stay
tuned no he won't tell us anything I
hate massive massive announcement I'm
excited to announce it's finalized so I
can I can say it's here because we
signed the contract yesterday it's going
to be big can't wait to announce that
part Dylan Mulvaney's coming here
oh my gosh we gotta ask on how did how'd
you get all those deals for those of you
guys that want to be informed the next
time we have a guest at the podcast and
you want to be the first to know about a
text award podcast to
310-340-1132 once again text award
podcast to
310-340-1132 one last thing because it's
the weekend sorry sorry to cut you off
but we have to do this it's a very
important weekend why this is Easter
weekend we're in the middle of Ramadan
and it's also Passover oh wow so one of
our beautiful
value Tanners brought you Pat some
matzah
these are the Mexican version of
tortillas and chips so we'll have some
matzah but I wanted to make sure to give
our Muslim friends some credit
oh this who was it yeah let's give them
a shout out they gave gifts to Rudy they
gave them in the front what was his name
his mother his mother sent them
uh uh thank you Eliza for this gift he
appreciate you yes hey
um happy Easter have a great day weekend
we'll do it again next week everybody
take care bye bye-bye